[Musique]
je peux t'appuyer je t'aime où es tu
pour dire j'ai une furieuse
journée ans catherine prochain et
capital conseille dans le problème à la
base pas au pied blague un acteur un
sportif parce que je suis de gauche ont
tous égyptiens
non je suis françois hollande sur sami
décoder tenue l'adoré c'est pourquoi
damman j'ai les jambes de sa femme ah
bah avec la mienne il aurait été calé
ils en auraient pas repris deux fois
tous les amoureux de son moniteur de ski
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il n'y avait pas
de la faire rire d une super tête donc
voilà ça va mieux la crise de la
quarantaine seulement rien à voir j'ai
38 ans alors l'amista du don d stresse
un peu la tête est formé par ailleurs
sexuelle c'est chiant c'est une menteuse
en aide
c'est facile à faire je peux
tentez pas mieux de te piquer un
héroïsme le stif tu m'a dit qu'il avait
juste eu des problèmes de 30 ans
[Musique]
aux amis
et un schéma allez on y va on se dit oh
ma faim tous les fils de sylla madame
quand vous m'appelez la dame est ce que
je vous appelle pp moi j'la mise ou
samedi la finance dans ton cul il va mal
[Musique]